30 hectares d'arbustes en plein milieu
de la Sologne et dessus des petites
baies bleues parfaitement mûres alignez
le Ribeau la cueillette des myrtilles
commence tout juste il y a 4 ans David
alexandre Bertrand découvre que ses
terres sont parfaitement adaptées à la
myrtille on a des sols sableux et acides
dans certains régions après il y a
d'autres coins dans la Sologne ou c'est
un peu argileux mais à nous de trouver
les endroits où on a du sable et on a
donc le pH de sol idéal pour pouvoir
produire de la myrtille en France en
reprenant la ferme familiale il y plante
cette variétés différentes pour pouvoir
étaler la récolte par exemple ici c'est
vraiment le stade de récolte pour
aujourd'hui on voit très bien ça se
détache bien là on a un deuxième stade
qui sera plutôt pour dans 8 jours
et puis ici pour dans 15 jours des
variétés de bouche destiné à être mangé
tel quel 2 tonnes récoltées chaque jour
puis soigneusement emballés avant de
partir vers des supermarchés un peu
partout en France comme ici à 30 km du
lieu de récolte elles sont bonnes elles
sont propres
sont bien mis en valeur nous l'habitude
de manger des framboises des fraises et
tout ça mais myrtilles non en France la
consommation de myrtilles d'écoles
multipliée par 6 ces 10 dernières années
mais pour l'instant elles sont
principalement importés d'Espagne et du
Maroc
ce chef étoilé a découvert cette petite
baie aux États-Unis et depuis qu'elles
sont cultivées juste à côté de son
restaurant il ne peut plus s'en passer
si en France on en avait jusqu'à présent
mais ça venait souvent justement soit
d'Amérique du Sud ou d'autres pays là
aujourd'hui on a de la myrtille et de
chez nous la myrtilles de Sologne qui
est produite en France c'est magique
grâce à une météo clémente la récolte
pour 2023 s'annonce abondantes la
filière estime que 3000 tonnes de
myrtilles seront produites en France
cette année